à bord du clemenceau s'achève la
deuxième journée de recherche du
sous-marin la minerve
cet énorme bateau la plus grosse unité
de la marine nationale a parié en un
temps record hier de toulon aujourd'hui
s'il écope d accueil derrière ont
effectué près de 60 rotations ils se
sont posés sort décoller il était 17h30
la soupe du commandant cousteau faisait
surface
trois heures plus tôt un avion
atlantique équipé d'un détecteur
magnétique avait capté un écho sonore
parfaitement localisés mais avant
d'avoir fait surface
les occupants de la soucoupe avait
transmis par radio nous remontons la
masse qui gît par le fonds n'est pas la
minerve
pas très certain c'est qu'il y avait un
écho et vous l'avez localiser je voulais
quelque chose
on a eu du mal
on a fini dans le retrouver j'ai bien
cru vainqueur monter sans arriver à leur
tour elle fera sa rentrée
je
pendant une seconde on a une émotion se
trouvait brusquement devant
your eyes de faire
noël une grosse marrade 10 mètres de
haut
il est là depuis très longtemps de ce
qu'elles étaient incrustées de
agression roja pour une
à quelle profondeur 140 malheureusement
été jour qui passe l'espoir disparaît
mais il reste quand même une chose à
faire c'est de trouver les causes même
si c'est dans un mois et je retrouvais
s'était pas mis volvo l'identifier vous
savoir pourquoi il a coulé le faut
[Musique]